we are sincerely committed to continue
to assist at our fullest capacity to
prevent drug
trafficking
namely the entrance of fenel and other
chemical
precursors President Biden meeting with
Mexican president orador who claims he
is going to help secure the Border but
is it all just a little too little and
too late cities across the country now
facing the impact of Biden's border
policies including right here in New
York city so let's break down the
effects just on the Big Apple more than
140,000 migrants have entered the city
since last spring with an average of 600
migrants entering every single day the
city's shelter program houses over
65,000 people with estimates up to
100,000 next fiscal year the migrant
influx has already cost the city $2
billion this fiscal year mayor Eric
Adams War warns migrants that are
expected to bring a price tag of $12
billion over the next three uh fiscal
years this is creating a budget cuts in
every single City Department including
New York's finest the NYPD is set to
reduce up to
29,000 cops by the end of 2025 a number
that the city hasn't seen since the mid
90s police and fire budgets have been
slashed by 206 million next year
creating an estimated budget gap of over
$7
billion so here with what this means for
New York City as migrants continue to
pour in former NYPD in uh inspector Paul
marrow Paul this is so fascinating to me
because I I'm still old enough to
remember oh I don't know just a few
years ago Democrats complaining
about5 to 7 billion dollar for a wall
and and I'm looking at these numbers
that's just New York City every single
city in America is facing this and some
of these are are cities that are much
smaller communities with far less
resources than New York City right so in
New York here obviously we have the
media as well so that's why it's
dominating headlines and this is
undeniably going to have a negative
effect some of them are obvious some of
them less so um things like response
times are going to be down is just going
to be less cops and cars Etc one of the
other things that you don't hear a lot
about is the uh effect on police
omnipresence and this is an under
discussed aspect of police work when the
cops are out there they're in uniform
especially young cops want to get
involved you see them essentially it's
preventive it's prophylactic people
behave and if you have a couple of cops
standing in Times Square or on the beach
someplace in one of the Burrows people
will tend to at least in that area it's
just common sense and when you're down
to 29,000 and by the way it's no
accident that the Renaissance in New
York City that occurred beginning in the
90s leading up to I would argue the
DeBlasio Administration it's no accident
that that dovetails perfectly with the
increase in the headcount of the mypd
when you have safety people come of
course of course meanwhile as we talked
about earlier um Biden met with
President obor they discussed illegal
immigration they discuss fentanyl
trafficking NYPD reports that the
migrant crisis has taken such a large
toll on the city's budget they're only
going to have 29,000 cops by 2025 it's
just so interesting to talk here
president um the president of Mexico say
you're it's so great that you you know
you're not you're you're you're not
you're not closing the Border you know
that you don't have a wall um it's just
unbelievable but the impact on
individual cities and individual
families is is just tremendous I mean
the the cause and effect here is just so
undeniable you have to wonder how long
Washington and I'm pinning this on
Washington how long Washington can just
deny the obvious if you don't have a
southern border and you're having all of
these folks coming in all day every day
and by the way we all know most of them
are economic refugees right I mean
that's just to me a settled issue um you
know you're not going to be able to feed
and have their care and feeding is so
completely on the government that it's
obviously going to break the bank but I
will say this Rachel a lot of this
sounds a little bit it's starting to
sound to me a little bit like
scapegoating and let's go back to the
previous administration the Blasio
Administration $ 1.3 billion dollar
dedicated to thrive New York a mental
health initiative here in the city that
was supposed to help clean up the mental
health issue on our streets things have
only gotten significantly worse first
lady wasn't the first lady in charge of
that that's right know what happened to
that money so where did that go since
Eric Adams has hit office we've had at
least 10 new city agencies I'd like to
see an audit of the city employment
roles because okay the migrants are
putting unprecedented pressure on New
York City that's undeniable on cities
across the country but this is the
culmination of years of financial
mismanagement Democratic laress run the
printing presses essential we can spend
money wherever we want that that
dovetails as well with what New York
City has been doing it's not just
Washington and as a result there's money
flying all over the place there's every
possible Social Service realistic uh
realistically in a lot of areas in New
York City especially in the homeless
Services area the whole thing's a
patronage Mill and if it's not looked at
more closely independent of the migrant
issue then it's never going to be solved
it's a terrible situation I don't know
how New Yorkers keep putting up with it
Paul Morrow thanks for joining us thank
you I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and
I'm Angley aart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis